what did she say she dogged them oh
the whole thing was a boodle small
wrench horrible in bed bad breath
terrible breath didn't go down to me
cheap
date brought me to a crappy restaurant
like you couldn't have seen
[Music]
what's up gang it's rear admiral from
spit and chicklets here my compadres
biz nasty and ryan whitney and we had to
play ask the internet
answer the anthony [ __ ] that up all
right if someone texts you a picture of
your dick with no context would you know
it's your deck
one thousand percent i can actually tell
you for a fact ask anyone in the bu
hockey team my junior year
i was able to name every guy just by
looking at their dick that's a fact
known to man 2004
bu hockey team i knew every person's
face by their dick
yeah no mine's uh it's uh it's ugly and
uh
it was actually recently in a
documentary my octopus teacher
so uh take a look at it
i think it won an oscar as well would
you already [ __ ] what an oscar
unfortunate unfortunately i probably
would recognize it uh trivia though my
dick has never been texted i'm happy to
say really
not a boy all right yeah it's been
sculpted send it to me yeah yeah yeah
how are you doing
the dick
postal service for a dick pic in my day
they said they did sculptures
all right business you want to do the
honestly i can't read
if you could be a superstar athlete in
any sport but you couldn't have sex
oh jesus would you golf
i don't think he finished would you do
it would you would you
would so you have to crank it off no sex
no sex so as long as i could
as long as i could still please my wife
i don't know [ __ ] bill clinton
can't touch women [ __ ] blow jobs and
not sex well i mean
so i couldn't i couldn't take care of my
wife in other ways because i you know
that ain't going to last married
although if i'm like babe we're making
25 sheets a year playing on the bj tour
that's what i mean and i gotta go yeah
yeah give me give me give me give me a
green jacket and i'm done with sex
what about going what about going down
in your pocket and you end up nothing
anyways is that sex or is that just the
lucky
freebie are you going down on your
that my legs of 30 plus she has a sex
that it might not have happened
twice you know like you get so caught up
in the moment that hey
like maybe rubbing off the bottom of the
mattress or something and you're like
all right no i don't think i would i
don't think i don't think i i don't
think a lot of people would think that
i agree i agree with people who have
been all [ __ ] up and
and they're broke with nothing without a
pot to piss in but no i'm not taking
that i might do it like and just be like
a short-term superstar athlete like
three years just
go wild for no you can't now he's
reinventing the question
yeah yeah you're changing the cards all
right how would you rank the four major
sports playoffs i'm going to go nhl
stanley cup playoffs no doubt i'm then
going to go
baseball the race to the world series
i'm then going to go football
get to the super bowl some of the wild
card games are boring and basketball is
the worst league in the world so i'm
[ __ ] with that league
he said it um stanley cup first uh
baseball as much as the sport sucks now
the playoffs are great i like hoops i
think this year hopefully he'll change
things up to get some new people in
there
and football as good as the super bowl
is i think there's an awful lot of duds
for as many big
big times big time would you rather [ __ ]
the hottest girl celebrity who has a
dick
or a vin diesel with the [ __ ]
i mean i just answered that question
i've already [ __ ] worse than vin
diesel with a [ __ ] so
i'll probably just stick with that i
mean it's [ __ ] how ping on the inside
as they say i'm just picturing having
sex with a hot chick who's got a
it's like the dick's touching my leg and
stuff
yeah like where's the placement going
you know no i
but then you gotta [ __ ] then vin diesel
with a [ __ ] i guess i'll fix
i don't know i don't know i don't know
an answer i got two kids and me
answering this i feel like that could
like make them knock it into high school
i'll beat it right now i'm not touching
that question
that could be an expensive expensive
answer your son didn't get into fair
academy because you talked about banging
a rocket with it yeah and here are your
divorce papers yeah
i'm gonna get but at least i'm in the
pga tours though
[Laughter]
if you could live anyone's life in their
body
who would you be uh who was that guy in
that netflix video you just showed up
today
liv anyone you pick anyone's body and
you get so are you you're them
you're just yeah you live anyone's life
in their body who would you be
i think um i think i would probably at
this point in time given like
how fun of a life he probably gets to
live is uh lewis hamilton
i was just thinking an f1 racer yeah
lewis hamilton although hey now
now carter yeah
yeah you're also you're you're you're
putting your life at risk but maybe
that's not the bad but i i'll stick with
lewis hamilton because of my first
answer and i think he was
was he not with rihanna at one point
like he's his rolodex of of
of them i think give me uh you know the
looks the the the scoring ability give
me cristiano ronaldo
pretty fun to be him for a couple days
not too bad i have similar abs
is how he does this what did you pick
all right i mean i
made the netflix guy joke because he he
said he was you you just want a massive
wrench um no i
don't want that but he was in good shape
too so i mean yeah that's probably a
pretty good answer because that's
basically what he was in good shape
would you rather walk with a rollerblade
on your left shoe for the rest of your
life
or have an angry [ __ ] walking in front
of you slightly slower than you want to
go for the rest of your life
that question is like 10 years old oh
the first dude honestly
i'm getting on that left wheel and i'm
gliding around the city and never
dealing with some [ __ ] you want to
punch out of your way
that's a rollerblader i think i could be
patient enough uh
wait no he this is behind him the guy's
like speed up
[Laughter]
that one doesn't bother me um i mean
when i walk in with a roll bit of one
left shoe that's basically me roll blade
anyways yeah i'll probably go with the
angry [ __ ] i just try to get stoned
and get a kick out of it every day
i think the fighting the blade would be
nice oh yeah dude if i could
blade on one like an ostrich i mean a
[ __ ] flamingo sure but
i can't so that's a [ __ ] broken nose
waiting to happen
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for
never been kicked out of a box um i was
just saying well i have
i mean probably [ __ ] puking maybe i
mean that's but everyone did that
i mean i never i never got caught over
spending too long on the small way
just um just a bar scrap yeah yeah
scraps never been kicked out of a bar
which fictional character would you love
to beat this
frost from friends i [ __ ] hate that
guy
i think he's one of the biggest goon
clown
characters in tv history i hated him the
whole show
i would say the whole the whole [ __ ]
cast of big bang theory kick them all
right in the [ __ ] face
i hated friends and mainly because of
ross
i don't i don't have an answer off the
top of my head but i'll pick one of the
bang guys so members yes if you were a
general in the civil war and you could
get a t-rex or modern war tank to fight
on your side
what are you taking holy wow that's it
i'll probably pick a t-rex
what side
[Laughter]
the civil war you could get a t-rex or
modern war tank to fight on your side
what are you taking now i'm actually
switching up my answer because i don't
think those muskets will do [ __ ] against
a tank you just [ __ ]
everything you think i'm muscular doing
something to it but
i'm definitely taking the t-rex because
what if you get them in the eye a tank
huh
enough soldiers can overrun a tank get
inside whatever get past it
so it won't affect you but you cannot
not with muscular cannot contain a t-rex
during the civil war
at all just think like what they would
do if there's something you could come
up with crashing like the south to see
the [ __ ]
jurassic park style [ __ ] that they just
see r.a leaving the club at 3am in miami
coming at him
watch out for late night would you [ __ ]
a porn star if afterwards she had to
hold the press conference on your
performance
absolutely not absolutely not
it already happened yeah fizz explained
to the folks at home
a local radio station stevie jones yeah
baby jones she
this is after she yeah yeah i had been
with gronk and uh
she yeah she wanted me to post a photo
of us at dinner and stuff like that i
obviously declined because i didn't want
anyone knowing that we were out together
other than the news station
who ended up getting her on the next
morning at 8 am to talk about my
performance
what did she say she dogged
[Applause]
brought me to a crappy restaurant like
you couldn't have she paid for rent she
went they went to red lobster dude took
her to red lobster
was it a bad performance or was she just
right no no the
the her boyfriend or partner at the time
yeah bizarro land was calling on the
phone the whole time it was
it was one of the most awkward
experiences i've ever been through
a big component as to why i'm like no
i'm not posting anything about being
associated with this
and then the following morning i mean it
was when you get dragged off
no no i got my phone was off the hook
the next morning and
we were playing the chicago blackhawks
that night and it was an important game
because we were in a playoff race
and i'm getting the call and then all of
a sudden i read the text from the guy at
the radio station being like hey
bibby's on and and she's carving you and
my heart is just
well i'm just hoping that the team
doesn't hear about it which i'm sure
that they did but what can you do if
you're getting graded on your bad
performance
as long as you're physical that night
biz that's all we care about
we're glad you we got you you held some
of that aggression for the game night
rather than
exerting it with bibby jones and uh you
think all the
employees here didn't want to get called
into bars two radio and porno is on
imagine b.b jones carving your [ __ ] up
on
on phoenix area scottsdale radio
yeah that was a tough scene though wwf
it's very
rare for these ridiculous questions that
someone has a real life story yeah
it's biz that happened 100 25 years old
college yeah nowadays i need a [ __ ]
roman sponsor and cialis sponsor and i'd
give it a whirl
fair enough get the waiver fair enough
for the old lady would you rather bang a
bunch of models but nobody knows or
actually or not actually [ __ ] them but
have everyone think you did 100 percent
bang a bunch and nobody knows that's the
it's a total ego trip so as long as
you're [ __ ] getting it done and you
know that who gives a [ __ ] what
everybody else agreed all right
this guy just the answer i agree agreed
from the guy who is getting chirped on
local radio about crushing a porn star
[Laughter]
if there was a snail following you for
the rest of your life and if you touched
it you'd die
how long could you survive so this snail
like is out to get you
is trying to kill you it moves like a
normal snail moves
probably never touches you i mean i'm
live until 100 i have the best
like sense of awareness of what's around
me the thing wouldn't come close
yeah i would last for until my bad
habits caught up with me this
[ __ ] never would you
let me ask you a question can it can it
fly if you get on a plane
yeah and it knows to get on point yeah
it can't fly like so
so it's like that movie what was that
recent movie the thing came back from
space and it was eating through everyone
creepy ending yeah creepy ending but it
connor you're right you're reminding me
of uh
that's the snail i'm thinking yeah it
still wouldn't get me yeah did somebody
get you
no so you fly across the country right
but then
you've lost sight of this [ __ ] snail
you never know where it is ever again
you go to sleep every night and you're
like maybe the snail's in the room you
don't know just you just see where he
went last time it takes
you can walk the door oh i'd have a
snail with an iphone i'd have find my
iphone locked to that thing i'd always
know where he was
i don't smart that i get a restraining
order
all right or or just surround you if you
touch it you die
just build up
he was looking for that snail when b.b
jones on the radio kill me now
it was right here the whole time
all right thanks for watching spitting
chicklets on answer the internet make
sure you like comment and subscribe
leave a comment below on who you'd like
to see on future episodes of answer the
internet
click here to download the app click
there